Were Trump supporters a monolithic
group of people with identical opinions?
The Democracy Fund Voter Study Group recently
looked at the data, and Dr. Emily Ekins
identified five separate clusters of his
supporters. Staunch conservatives were
the largest group. These people are loyal
Republicans, solid fiscal conservatives,
and have traditional values. A second
group of his supporters – free marketeers –
favor smaller government, have moderate
to liberal social views, and support free
trade. The third group are what Ekins
called the "anti-elite". These people are
more progressive and see the economic
and political system stacked against
them. Still another group, the disengaged,
are only about 5% of his supporters. A
final group, what Ekins called the
American preservationist might be the
most significant for Trump because they
propelled him to the nomination. They
support higher taxes on the rich, like
the social safety net, and are free trade
skeptics. There is overlap among the groups, but
the big takeaway from Ekins' analysis is
that there is no such thing as a single
kind of Trump voter.
To learn more about
my take on the different kinds of Trump voters,
check the links in the description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you want our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.